6 37 as we mentioned we have breaking
news this morning in the Mountain's Edge
neighborhood in the southwest Valley
Metro Police are investigating a murder
this is Jones and Cactus a mother
allegedly killed by her own daughter
here's our Candace Charles live at the
scene with what we have just learned
Candace
yeah it is quite a violent situation we
want to remind folks about that but as
you can see it is still quite an active
scene and has been that way since about
2 30 this morning here in her Jones and
Cactus 9-1-1 dispatch got a call from a
frantic woman saying her mother was dead
before the call disconnected now when
officers got to June Flower Drive they
found 62 year old woman dead officers
say she had deep lacerations and that
there was a lot of blood at the scene as
far as a suspect here what officers had
to say
we started looking for a daughter we now
have that daughter stopped and in
custody uh in Barstow California
with the help of California Highway
Patrol that occurred about 5 a.m this
morning
no there's not many more details beyond
that as this is an early investigation
of course as we learn more we will let
you know more police say they have to
speak more with the daughter and the
neighbors as well again as we learn more
we'll bring you more so sick with us
right here on air online and on social
for the latest for now live from Jones
and Cactus I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now